first of all before I say good evening
to everybody can I first of all
introduce Mr Michael Clark and Peter Mr
Peter Lorenzo who are both independent
members on the standards committee I
think it's the first time both of you
have been to one of the crwp meetings so
and you'll get to know as we go along
the routine don't worry
so welcome to both of you
all right good evening members and
officers of the council and members of
the public welcome to the meeting of the
Constitutional review working party
fire evacuation procedure if the fire
alarm is activated please vacate the
offices via the stairs either through
the security doors or opposite that
lives in the foyer do not use lifts
please assembling all the square on the
green and officers will assist you and
advise you when it's deemed safe to
return to the chamber does anyone intend
to film the meeting
any member of the public didn't know it
let me roll that out
will everybody present please ensure
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and they are not used to make or receive
phone calls in the chamber while the
meeting is in progress please note this
meeting has been live stream for members
of the public except for any items of
business or exempt or confidential
information is considered following the
exclusion of the press and public from
the meeting this meeting is also being
recorded and will be broadcast on the
internet
would any member who wish to speak under
Council procedural 20.1 please announce
it
are there any apologies or absence
no no Chad
are there any decorations of Interest
right minutes of the meeting from the
23rd of February 2022 I move that the
minutes of the meeting held on the 23rd
of February 2022 can be approved and
signed as a correct record
could I have a second to please
thank you
unless anyone on the objects I will take
them as agreed
thank you
item four agendum agenda item four
revised members of the code of conduct
I'll ask Mr Hughes the committee
services manager to present the report
thank you chairman
um
so uh
I'm just going to introduce the report
I'm I don't propose to go through all
the changes but there are one or two
that I wanted to pick out and to get
members opinions on so
um the local government Association have
um in the past six months released a new
model code of conduct
we as a council have a current code of
conduct that is created by the Kent
secretaries group so that is a group of
all the monitoring officers across Kent
and they have created a code that is
used a sense of the across Kent there
are sort of minor differences between
all of them but on the whole it's pretty
much the same in order to ensure that we
have a a Level Playing Field for for
members conduct across Kent
um due to obviously the local
governmentization local government
Association publishing a new model code
uh the Kent secretary took the
opportunity to review the current one
um and update it and and make some
changes uh those changes are then uh
outlined uh within the report at
paragraph two and also in the annex at
the uh the end of the document uh and uh
as it has been pointed out do apologize
that um The Columns are not in the same
order in this report as they are in the
second report just to keep you all on
your toes yeah
um so
um as you can see from the changes most
of them are um
removing repetition and removing
removing ambiguity
um
the ones that I would particularly uh
draw your attention to is the limit on
um gifts and hospitality
currently the TDC Constitution says that
members should declare within 28 days
any gift benefit or Hospitality over 25
pounds the Kent code AS is proposed is
100 pounds and obviously that's based on
the LJ model code of conduct so members
may wish to consider whether or not
um they wish to uh disregard that change
and keep the level for family at 25
pounds uh or or some other amount and I
would also draw your attention to the
fact that
um a couple of I think it was last year
we included a specific definition of
anti-seven anti-semitism uh into our
members of code of conduct and by
default that's not included in the LGA
model code of conduct so again here
members may wish to retain that
definition in our new amended code okay
if members have any questions about any
of the other points
then obviously please feel free to ask
any questions
thank you
me I'm afraid
because when it came to page 11 it's
taking part in discussions that amended
code of conducts that sentence it was
torturous I still don't quite understand
it because someone explained it to me
taking this step in relation to a
massive being dealt with by you acting
alone in the course of discharging a
function of the authority except
the step for the purpose of enabling the
matter to be dealt with otherwise than
by you
didn't understand that very much sorry
which one are you referring to sorry
yeah it's it's
about where
members certain members are taking
individual decisions so with regards to
like cabinet individual Cabinet member
decisions
the way
yeah theoretically you could
have a you could take an individual
Cabinet member decision rather than
taking it to a meeting where there would
been a vote where you would have had to
have declared an interest
ing is that yeah
yeah it could be yeah it's not massively
yeah
not wishing that this was written by
many solicitors with many many
solicitors
but no I think that's a fair point we
can we can
certainly look to amend it to retain the
the
yeah but with a slightly easier wording
yeah
just to add it wasn't me who minded that
can I just ask has anybody got any
comments on the hospitality gift value
Council Ashby
I seen this earlier
um for some reason well in anticipation
um
obviously there's different levels of
um uh
uh that counselors might be expected to
attend obviously as leader um I go to
various things and I think the 25 I just
asked basically what year was the 25
pound set because if it was a long while
ago I mean I'm not trying to go around
and
and truffle up a lot of hundred pounds
as leader of the council but I do feel
that 25 is quite low
for the leader and for the and for the
cabinet which might have to uh I mean we
have to fund our own travel within
District but you do get invited to a
huge amount of um different different
events and I could find myself in an
embarrassing position where I often get
asked to go and speak at say rotary or
some sort of you know where they provide
me sustenance because
you know you've been out so it's
difficult it would be
I mean it was not embarrassing but if if
they invite me then they automatically
invite me for the dinner so then I'd
have to inquire us to live with the
dinner cost more than 25 pounds and uh
you know
um it I just think that maybe in some
levels so maybe a hundred pounds would
would make more sense and then that
would be a sort of catch-all
yeah so I mean presumably 25 was set I
don't know if you know when it was set
but that'll be a question and but
um so so that's my thoughts on that I
mean that's just sort of personal
experience I suppose
um but uh yes I think I would
certainly endorse it but not for my own
benefit but just for to keep down maybe
some of the administration that's been
asked to say
um the other thing I would like to say
is that um
absolutely I love the way this is set
out because you know rather than having
to go through and work out amendments I
mean to do it like this is just so much
easier for members of the committee I
mean not that I don't love trawling
through the Constitution and working out
the differences um on it but uh this is
so com compliments to to the to the
setting out of this and thank you to for
the officers involved um
the the other point I mean it's another
point on another on another matter so if
I do them all at one go
um
am I right in thinking that this code of
conduct applies to every single
counselor across so I.E Parish Council
Town Council
District Council County councilor and
also do
is the uh what's the right word gotta be
careful here the sanctioning of of these
these um the conduct would they be dealt
with in the same manner as
um is I mean for instance do standards
have to deal with TDC standards
committee deal with Parish Council and
town and just just a bit of clarity on
that because I'm not entirely sure
whether I think some maybe Parish
councils um might be referring to Jackie
whatever her name was the the behavior
there but you know it's just I don't
think maybe parish and town councils
maybe feel that they actually come under
the same stringent control that we do
but I think they probably do it's just
it's not understood that fully so just
some clarity on that thank you chair
um yeah so going to the the first point
about the the setting of the value
um
if memory server is going to be correct
it was 2012 when the last code of
conduct was put in
um and even then I can remember from
members who are now
no longer with us
um that there was a massive argument
then about it being it was reduced from
I can't remember what it was I think it
was 50 but it was certainly dropped down
for thanet to 25 from whatever the level
was back in 2012.
um so yeah it stayed at 25 for at least
10 years so that's
first point
um
the code of conduct and uh who applies
to yes yes the Kent code applies to all
of the
um Democratic bodies so all three tiers
um within
um within Kent
obviously they will have slightly
amended
different slightly different versions of
the Kent code but essentially it's all
based on the same document for example
like ours has a our standards
Arrangements have an independent member
or independent members in it not
everybody else's does some councils have
a standard as in governance committee
joined together so there's small tweaks
like that but essentially yes the same
principle applies across for all three
tiers
yes in thanet all of the parish councils
have agreed to sign up to this
particular code
so in damnit they all have exactly the
same there is a subtly different one the
version that they have is something
different from ours because obviously it
refers to
blank insert name here
but the content is the same I mean typos
and and small details like that are
different but um yes essentially it's
exactly the same
is that helpful
I think you'll also find counter-strate
it's written in the papers further in as
we go if there is a discipline hearing
involving a member of the town or Parish
Council then the standards committee or
the monitoring officer would actually
notify the secretary of the relevant
Council in relation to the judgments and
the progress I did mention in my annual
report that I was hoping that we myself
and monitoring officer or somebody could
go around to all the councils to
reiterate our existence because I have
concerns like you do I think that they
don't realize that we're here and
um
obviously with a change of personnel
within the offices and that's been a
little bit difficult I was happy to do
it on my own but I was fortunate I was
advised no take something from
democratic services with you obviously
to explain what's what so that was the
idea behind it but of course it would
change Personnel it's not come to a
fruition as yet
that's kind of so hard uh thank you Mr
tuck I believe
um well I know that some of the parish
councils are aware of our existence and
the controls that we have and the
complaint procedure because that's
happened
um that I know of so I know that does
happen but I do think that what you're
suggesting is a very good idea and I
think most Parish councils would be very
grateful for the fact that you would go
around to one of the parish meetings or
the town meetings and explain the rules
with regards to the disciplinary actions
that can be taken against them because I
think you're quite right some are very
lacks in their
um
attitudes towards gender and everything
else and I think that is quite right
that we actually put it right now and
that you know they can be hauled up for
it and I think that is an issue and I
think most of them I don't see any
reason why they wouldn't be acceptable
for that but as you say maybe Tamira
ought to go with you as well
or somebody else of equal standing
thank you for that and I think it is
something that now you've raised it we
need to discuss it I know on the
standards committee we do have
representatives from The Villages and
parishes and I believe misuse will
correct me if I'm wrong there is a
member of Ramsgate Town Council on the
standards
I think I'm not too sure do you know
Council Ashby
no I'm trying to think if it is
sorry apologies
um no there are there are Parish members
yes
they're not from Ramsgate Town Council
yeah there might be yeah there might be
twin Hatters the the parish one is
um Derrick Crow Brown and
uh the other chat from manston who's
um a quick uh
Mr Clinton yes yeah sorry
yeah I I'm aware of that from
I I'm aware of that as well from recent
activity that yes we have touched base
with the new
um Clark of the ramsgo council I only
wanted to raise the issue of find that
the financial issue because it's
something that I think should be
mentioned just so that we all talk from
the same Level Playing Field and there's
no disputes later if you like
yeah that's why I just thought just make
sure everybody's
um yeah I I think uh if that limit
applies to Parish council's turn counts
as well then making them aware of that
as part of the overall code would be
really really helpful
um May I just sound one other issue on
the anti-Semitism Clause
um I was because I think we're talking
about sort of helping Rey stands around
things like gender and representation
and so on as well
um I wondered why that wasn't in the LGA
recommended advice I think it should be
in but I don't know whether Mr Hughes
can say whether there's any particular
reason why the LGA are not recommending
or just it's probably not something
that's they've thought to cover I don't
know
I I'm not in a position to answer that
I'm afraid I I wouldn't know why they
wouldn't include it I do know that not
all councils have a definition of
anti-semitism in it
um but um I'd say I mean we we put our
well this is the
our definition is the official
definition
um as per the appropriate authorities I
can't remember off the top of my head
what the the proper Authority is but it
was written by them and we've put it
into our our code of conduct
um that we're quite happy to include it
I think it's as you said it's an
important thing to include definitely
I just wanted to say uh to second that I
think it's very important that we have
it in and for clarity that we have that
definition as distinct from the ihra one
that's all about the state of Israel and
that has caused such such confusion I
think we if we've got something that's
simple and straightforward that people
understand we should have it in why not
yeah I read that and I thought well why
just anti-Semitism you could include
other things as well
um because I thought well what about
um
defining under the equality act 2010 and
the public sector Duty stuff because
that covers everything
um and I thought and I'm just going to
say this that was put in for political
expediency at the time
um I agree with it but it should cover
more than just anti-semitism
wide stretching discrimination within
um the conduct this is just this was a
specific thing that was raised by a
member that was bought to full Council
so we endorsed it I think it's
it's it's as well as
um and it's it's it was specifically
um raised that full Council and we
agreed that it was
um absolutely necessary but there is an
overarching obviously discrimination
against any any type of discrimination
it's just that a member bought this as a
specific and I don't know whether it was
a result of some event that might have
gone on within the district so they
wanted to actually he said like a double
stamp if you like so I think that's why
it all came about in fact I was at the
council when it was discussed and it was
obviously agreed but um I think that was
one of them so they didn't feel that um
the the general discrimination conduct
code of conduct was wide enough to Curry
cover this particular because there was
a specific incident within uh within a
dis with within the district so I
believe that's what it was if that makes
any sense to you
in that case but my few still stands in
that it's not just I can understand why
it was was brought up but it it should
cover
all religious intolerance
rather than just anti-semitism
that's all I'm saying
do members wish to make any
recommendations to the standards
committee
in that case can I have a proposer for a
gender item four and a second
sorry check so I'll be saying that the
I think the views whether we should
stick to 100 pounds and to retain the
yeah so just to make that clear for the
best of the minutes
yeah yeah that's fine yeah
yeah no that's fine cool
I think it's just because it's
the things we've just agreed aren't in
the version they're not in the version
that I've put to you that's that's why I
wanted to make it clear that we want to
put them back in oh yeah no yeah
thank you chairman
um so
um this is an extension of the previous
um item so
um
although
um as we talked previously about the
model code of conduct from the LGA they
didn't produce any complaint handling
Guidance the complaint handling
Arrangements were designed by by the Ken
secretaries group but obviously as the
code of conduct change they took this as
an opportunity as I've already said it
was previously last looked at
extensively in in 2012 with the
introduction of localism act 2011.
um so they took an opportunity to look
again at the the complaint handling uh
legislation oh sorry complaint handling
guidance that they've put together so
again
um I won't go through all of them
um
the mainly it's about time limits and
they're extending them and I would
acknowledge that some of the extensions
do look quite a long time
however uh not that I'm here to justify
other people's changes however having
been involved in some of these they are
an incredibly time consuming and
extremely sensitive thing to manage and
the time scales within the original
no that's not very helpful my computer's
just throwing me out
um
the um original time scales are not uh
really achievable uh if we're being
honest
um
okay so with
no just threw me out
oh hang on Airways
Fairways
um so if I can I'll come back to that
point if that's all right
um so
again there's only a few things that I
would
um
draw to members attention
um
the first of all is the membership of
hearings uh item on page
36.
um
as I've said previously a lot of other
councils don't have independent members
on their their panels
um so this is written with a view of
um having no independent members as we
do I think it would be advisable for us
to retain the existing procedure whereby
the the um one of the independent
members has to be the chair of a
hearings panel I think that's probably
worth definitely keeping
um
the uh to do
one of the other things is
um
it's worth also noting that failure to
comply with a sanction
would actually be a breach of the code
because currently it isn't so we can go
through the whole process and say you
need to apologize and the counselor at
the moment can go no
and there's nothing whatsoever that the
panel can do about it whereas if in
future we say or the panel says
apologize and they go no I'm not going
to do it that at least is another breach
of the code there would be in breach of
of that which is quite a helpful
um
inclusion
um
you would go through the process again
so it would be essentially that yeah you
would potentially come up with a
different sanction so you'd have that
first complaint which obviously was
proven we've asked you to apologize for
it then you go through another process
similar that says right okay these
people didn't apologize and obviously
you'd take that into account when it got
to the end so you would ask for a a more
significant sanction I would imagine at
the end of that process if they were
found guilty
which could be basically taking the
member of the particular committee that
they're actually at or they could be
asked to not attend a particular area so
for example they were on
um they were a portfolio holder just an
example they'd be taken off that I'm not
allowed to attend our committee for
three to six months that's one of the
sanctions that can be applied
is there any way of making that slightly
quicker to do because it feels like it
is quite a long process as we're saying
and then to go into it again and
effectively rerun it is there any way of
sort of shortening that at all or
bringing that forward more quickly
I don't think you could you'd have to go
through the proper processes and I'm
afraid there isn't shortcut to it as
much as we'd like it to be it has to be
done properly
unfortunately a lot of our teeth I think
is the right expression was taken away
by Mr Pickles when he removed a lot of
what the standards committee could
impose if somebody was found guilty of
breaching the code of conduct so our
powers are very very limited I think
that's right Mr Hughes isn't it that is
correct yes it was actually taken away
in fact England is the only one that's
taken away is still applicable in in
Wales and Scotland so they still follow
prosecution but in England we can't do
any
uh just a one other thing
um and thanks to councilor Hart for
pointing this out
um at page uh to do 54
um for Steve's benefit
um we've got a a gender specific term in
there uh in the form in the sample
Complaint Form uh so we're just going to
remove that and change it to a gender
neutral one um other than that
everything else is
gender neutral as per our constitution
so
um was there another I did get another
question I think from
I'm happy to answer
um I don't know why the Ken secretary
actually went down this route I don't
know but very honestly it doesn't take
that long and I whenever I've done it
I've never gone for 20 days well I won't
go to Dunedin that's to show you it's
literally a standard email setting out
it's a 10 working days so even though
it's there I I can rest assure you that
you won't take 20 days
I'm happy to I mean as long as members
are I have no problem 10 working that is
fine
which is still two weeks so it's fine
that was the question I was going to ask
what are our powers now in relation to
any recommendations we make
can we we've got the power to leave ours
as they are
without
I.E the 10 working days being the
classic exam
absolutely we're only the council is
only required to have a code of conduct
it just so happens that in Kent we all
have the similar one
um so any of these changes you if you
don't like them or want to recommend
something else like we did with whether
we wanted to include the anti-seminism
definition or whether we wanted it to be
25 or 100 pounds it you can change it so
if you want this to be 10 days you can
keep it at 10 days if you wanted to
that's absolutely fine
really up to
um
I was I was involved with it with an
incident where it actually fell over the
Christmas period
so it actually was really really it did
actually affect
so maybe a suggestion could be to just
insert the word a maximum of 20 days so
then if the monitoring officer was of a
mind to do it within any a shorter
period than they can do there was an
instance when
um 10 days was breached because it fell
over
uh the monitoring officer was away and
they are the gatekeeper so
um and they were away and it was a
Christmas period and it and it it
breached it so
um I appreciate that you can probably do
it in 10 days in most circumstances but
maybe a catch-all is to have a maximum
of 20 just insert the word maximum and
then then obviously if the monitoring
officer can get it done in two days then
you know so be it but um it was just
there was an incident uh which I was
actually involved in so um and it was a
bit awkward
perhaps
get us absolutely fine with me I was
gonna suggest the work Indian right if
it's 10 working days the minimum will
turn and no more than 20 something like
that then that way it yeah yeah
um all I was going to say is that um I
have got a can secretary meeting next
week so I will raise it with them with
the Amendments that we've suggesting
just so they know
um that we actually have sort of some of
the stuff that we've gone away from
their recommendation just to put Belton
braces really more than anything else
show me you can't just ask you just for
everybody's benefit just to reiterate
what the two amendments we are look as
if we're going to be recommending this
evening
obviously the first one is
straightforward that add to a maximum of
20 working days
um no I think it's no minimum of 10
working days and with a maximum of 20
days yeah yeah okay
and in relation to the
um
independent members
on the hearing panels
we want ours to stay as stay as it is
my chair I mean I think that's really
important that we maintain an
independent chair because
um
not that you should enter this committee
with a political bias but obviously
having an independent chair would have
avoided that
I also
um I probably should know this but it's
not included in is the mechanism for
um it may well be bedded somewhere in
there but the mechanism for selection of
the subcommittee I'm just I've never
been clear
um on how that is actually selected and
I say it because of I worry
um about political bias so
um I just wondered how the selection
happens
just as a safeguard because I would hope
for for that to creep in I mean we had
an earlier conversation today about
where it can maybe
present gray areas so um just uh I mean
it's not covered in this but maybe it
should be and I can't find where we
cover the selection for subcommittees
for for standards
I'll let Mr Hughes answer that so
um as you originally said cancer the the
idea is that it's an apolitical
uh role however obviously
uh it's more what it's seen about from
outside rather than what is seen from
inside
um so given the fact there aren't any
official rules uh when Democratic
Services
have to select members from from the
panel we always ensure that there is one
member so it's a panel of three so you
have your independent
member he had the independent chairman
and occasionally you have another you
have another independent member
um and that will happen more so now uh
previously it didn't happen because we
didn't have enough independent members
but now we do so you'll have two
independent members and then you'll have
at least uh you'll have one counselor
from their group and one counselor
that's not of their group okay
um and if if the complaint is about a
parish counselor one of the people will
always be a parish counselor on that to
give to give a a fair Parish Council
viewpoint
well as well as there's only two there's
only two Parish Council Representatives
yes so if it is from the that's why we
always try and make sure that when the
parish
uh I think is it Association of local
councils I think are the people who put
the nominations in we always try to
ensure that they're not from the same
Parish Council
um so yeah we would try not to have
somebody from that Parish Council on the
on the on the on the selection panel
however
um obviously people are very busy
um and whilst that is an aspiration we
can't guarantee
as from what we're talking about with
regards to the the deadlines and the the
pressing need to get on with stuff we we
can't
just delay forever the ability to set up
a assessment subcommittee because the
balance isn't quite right so it might be
the case that we always try and have
somebody we will stick to those rules we
always try and do that however if people
are on holiday or people are just not
available then occasionally we would go
away from that but that is absolutely
the exception to the rule like I
personally can't remember
in my time in the 10 years I've been
here that happening more than a handful
of times in 10 years we always try and
keep it
not politically balanced but fair fair
so I think we can move forward then so
are we looking to recommend option three
one on page 39.
I.E the Amendments that we've just
suggested
I have a question awfully sorry um page
t
page 33 I'm confidentiality
I'm assuming the left hand is the left
hand is proposed and looked at the one
in his current have you not transposed
them
oh were you so it should be the other
way around okay fine
that's all I want to know you'll change
it then fine thank you
whichever you feel members
I think we could take it on block
because I think there's only two as such
isn't it
yeah okay
are we happy to take it on block
right in that case
yeah
so councilor Austin's proposing a second
to please
users got anything else to raise no well
that's it thank you very much ladies and
gentlemen